[Musica]
galileo galilei il padre della scienza
moderna nel suo dialogo sopra i due
massimi sistemi del mondo ha scritto è
la sola vista della figura mi ha
chiarito il tutto con questa frase viene
affermato il potere delle immagini delle
figure poi le parole servono arrivano
per decretare per descrivere per
spiegare vorrei che guardasse insieme a
me questa è un'immagine questa
fotografia scattata io rapporto al point
nella penisola antartica
alla fine dell'estate australe il colore
rossastro di queste fioriture di alghe è
provocato da un organismo unicellulare
appunto un'alga microscopica che rimane
inattiva durante tutti i mesi invernali
per poi risvegliarsi non appena le
temperature iniziano ad innalzarsi
quindi proprio durante i mesi estivi
le storie di queste alghe assumono la
caratteristica colorazione rosa rosso
scarlatto ed è dovuta ai carotenoidi che
vengono prodotti da queste alghe per
difendersi dai raggi ultravioletti del
sole
questo tono più scuro assorbe calore e
abbassa il di oltre il 10 per cento
l'albedo
è altro che il potere riflettente dei
ghiacci accelerandone quindi lo
scioglimento soprattutto durante i mesi
estivi con l'aumento della fusione
superficiale le aree dei ghiacci trovano
quindi un habitat ideale per la loro
riproduzione
e a sua volta questa situazione aumenta
lo scioglimento dei ghiacci e non
circolo vizioso di cui dovremmo tener
conto senza alcun dubbio nei prossimi
modelli climatici di questa regione
quindi la risposta biologica
riscaldamento globale è una risposta
pervasiva e la penisola antartica è
destinata a diventare in futuro un luogo
molto più colorato
mi parlò dell'antartide essenzialmente
perché l'ho visitata e sono stata in
visita in due basi scientifiche la base
di cannes a calmare la base inglese
rosea alla fine dell'estate australe nei
mesi di febbraio marzo del 2018
ho partecipato a una missione
scientifica con war bound un'iniziativa
australiana che vuole coniugare scienza
ambiente e leadership al femminile
questo progetto da un lato e vuole
mantenere alta l'attenzione sui temi
dell'emergenza climatica e il
riscaldamento globale dall'altro però
vuole anche promuovere la visibilità e
il ruolo delle donne scienziate che sono
ancora oggi sotto rappresentate nel
mondo tecnico scientifico
di stato la penisola antartica appunto
insieme a me sono partite 76 donne
scienziate
tutte con formazione scientifica di
diversa proprio una biodiversità di
informazioni scientifiche c'erano
fisiche come meno anche i biologi marini
e geologi ingegneri ambientali
e collo che marini ed esperte di
politiche ambientali
l'antartide è un luogo alieno
incontaminato è un ecosistema fragile ma
estremamente interessante per gli studi
climatici come l'amazzonia e il polmone
della terra così le tue aree polari sia
quella boreale quello australe sono
fondamentali per la circolazione
atmosferica e oceanica e anche per il
trasporto di calore e di energia su
scala globale
oggi lo studio dell'antartide e
dell'oceano antartico
significativi per mettere a fuoco i
cambiamenti del clima e anche per
riuscire a quantificare
l'influenza delle attività umane delle
nostre attività produttive sul
riscaldamento globale allo scopo di
mettere in atto delle misure di
intervento e di correzione
l'antartide diventata oggi senza alcun
dubbio il simbolo della velocità con cui
pianeta sta cambiando
credo che tutti abbiamo negli occhi le
immagini degli enormi distacchi di kata
forme cacciali penso al mega vestberg a
68 dell'ars in c che si è distaccato
nell'umile 2017 oppure al più recente a
76 nel maggio 2000 e 21 un iceberg
grande quasi quanto l'isola di maiorca e
benché il distacco degli iceberg sia un
fenomeno ciclico e fisiologico
non dimentichiamo che all'intera
criosfera su scala globale che sta
cambiando
la storia degli studi sul clima è
essenzialmente la storia della graduale
consapevolezza che l'uomo ha acquisito
sull'impatto che le sue attività hanno
riguardo al benessere e alla salute del
nostro pianeta dalla rivoluzione
industriale in poi
il pioniere di questi studi è stato un
fisico chimico svedese svante arrhenius
che nel 1896 per primo effettua alcuni
pionieristici studi sull'effetto serra e
studi e tengono conto proprio del
rilascio di gas di origine antropica i
calcoli di arrhenius erano rudimentali
goffi se confrontati per esempio con i
modelli climatici attuali sono anche dei
calcoli faticosi da seguire perché si
tratta di migliaia di equazioni buttate
giù con carta penna
uno dei lavori più noiosi della mia vita
dirà lo stesso arrhenius però i suoi
calcoli sono stati fondamentali per le
scienze climatiche
è anche vero che forse è mosso dallo
spirito positivista dell'epoca all.re
news
si disse convinto che i cambiamenti
climatici sarebbero stati lentissimi e
non sarebbero apparsi prima di circa
tremila anni noi sappiamo invece bene
oggi che siamo dopo più di un secolo
dopo appena più di un secolo siamo già
in piena emergenza climatica
nell'aprile del 2006 questa celebre
copertina della rivista time
invitava come come si legge ad essere
preoccupati ad essere molto preoccupati
su questo sfondo nero si vede un
solitario e malinconico orso polare
locato su una sottile lastra di ghiaccio
si trattava all'epoca di un tema poco
alla moda e sono quindici anni fa la
questione climatica non occupava alle
prime pagine di quotidiani non
interessava la maggior parte dei siti
d'informazione neanche le principali
riviste scientifiche
a differenza di quello che invece accade
oggi questa copertina che voleva dare in
qualche modo una scossa ai lettori venne
invece percepita come una comunicazione
minacciosa e apocalittica riguardo al
clima
il pessimismo o comunque una notizia un
modo di comunicare catastrofico
catastrofista spesso genera una sorta di
inerzia di deresponsabilizzazione
collettiva nei lettori come se non ci
fosse più nulla di concreto da fare e
questo è un rischio su quale dobbiamo
avvicinare perché per poter cambiare il
mondo di sicuro dobbiamo essere capaci
di immaginarne uno migliore
in conclusione chi è il cattivo della
storia siamo noi ora co2
oggi noi sappiamo che i comportamenti
umani stanno modificando la superficie
del pianeta
la nostra atmosfera in modo così
radicale da da rendere homo sapiens e
cioè noi un vero e proprio agente
geologico
anche i batteri avevano trasformato il
pianeta ma loro non lo sapevano in noi
piace oggi lo sappiamo non abbiamo più
scuse lei chi sì sì che il gruppo il
panel intergovernativo per i cambiamenti
climatici è l'organismo internazionale
che raccoglie e è valida i principali
studi scientifici sul clima è da circa
30 anni pubblica periodicamente dei
rapporti di valutazione
beh è interessante notare che in questi
rapporti si legge espressamente che la
probabilità che riscaldamento osservato
sia imputabile alle attività umane è
passata dall'essere compresa fra il 70 e
100 per cento come si legge nel report
nel 2007 all'essere compresa fra il 99 e
il cento per cento come si legge
nell'ultimo report che è dell'agosto
negli ultimi 200 anni quindi la
concentrazione di gas serra soprattutto
anidride carbonica è aumentata
nell'atmosfera principalmente a causa di
tre fattori tutte riconducibili alle
nostre attività
il primo è l'utilizzo dei combustibili
fossili
il secondo riguarda le pratiche di avere
cotture allevamento e il terzo è la
deforestazione che ha ridotto
sensibilmente l'assorbimento di co2 da
parte della vegetazione
la co2 né rete carbonica è presente in
atmosfera in una percentuale
la concentrazione di circa lo 0,04 per
cento
qualcuno potrebbe pensare che cosa sarà
mai qualche parte su 10.000
eppure ricordiamo che minime variazioni
di una variabile come accade per esempio
nei sistemi lineari e il clima è un
sistema lineare possono produrre
variazioni di portata molto
significativa quasi imprevedibile
riguardo agli effetti climatici su larga
scala
ecco questo grafico nasce dall'analisi
di da un lato cinquant'anni in ultimi 50
anni di monitoraggio della composizione
dell'aria effettuate dall'osservatorio
di chimica atmosferica di mauna loa
nelle isole hawaii e dall'altro i dati
raccolti che hanno permesso di disegnare
le questo grafico vengono da costruzioni
pare climatiche paleoambientali penso ai
carotaggi di ghiaccio prelevate in
antartide all analisi dei sedimenti dai
fondali oceanici
tutti questi dati ci dicono che
per centinaia di migliaia di anni
la concentrazione di co2 in atmosfera ha
oscillato fra i 180 e le 300 parti per
milione
oggi invece stabilmente sopra le 400
parti per milione
e non dimentichiamo che homo sapiens
cioè noi non ha mai respirato un'aria
così satura di co2 in conclusione quindi
che parole dobbiamo usare per parlare
per pensare alla terra deve usare le
parole della scienza le parole delle
mozioni come della statistica che cosa
che a noi la terra è una materia prima è
ancora sotto utilizzata ancora da
sfruttare o è una sacralità
incommensurabile
il concetto di natura come madre natura
un concetto antico e porta in sé l'idea
di una distensione fra i fenomeni
naturali sono immutabili che l'uomo non
può alterare invece i fenomeni umani
prodotti umani che sono transitori
modificato modificabili eliminabili ed è
un'idea suggestiva e insidiosa lo stesso
tempo questa perché
rischia di perpetuare la convinzione di
una natura capace di rigenerarsi una
natura capace di prendersi cura di sé
proprio come farebbe una grande madre in
grado comunque di garantire ad ogni
costo il suo corso e dunque noi
continuiamo a deforestare continuiamo a
inquinare a bruciare petrolio a produrre
co2 ad alterare ecosistemi come se
fossero qualcosa di altro da noi
del resto fu proprio durante la
rivoluzione industriale che iniziò a
diffondersi
un'idea di natura esterna l'uomo la
natura selvaggia
quasi una natura da dado masticare da
domare per impedire che fosse un
ostacolo allo sviluppo di una nuova era
eppure basta rileggere darwin nella sua
origine delle specie per ricordarsi che
la nostra specie era indissolubilmente
legata a tutte le altre da una fitta
rete di i meccanismi di selezione
relazione la cui integrità è vitale per
la nostra stessa sopravvivenza
ancor oggi dunque nonostante darwin e
nonostante i report climatici direi che
si si
stentiamo ad attribuire alla natura
un'idea di comunità e di alleanza tra
viventi non vivente grazie